dans les vosges peut-être un
retournement de situation dans la
célèbre affaire grégory sans entrer dans
le détail de la reconstitution on appris
aujourd'hui que grégory auraient été
noyés en plein centre du village de dos
elle et non à proximité du chemin
longeant la voie ferrée 100 ans sans
être décisif
cet élément est important car on étudie
maintenant l'hypothèse d'un meurtre
commis après 17h30 ce qui
innocenteraient christine villemin sur
place
reportage de roland sicard christine et
jean marie villemin une nouvelle fois au
coeur du drame comme si l'histoire
commencé ce matin le juge maurice simon
les emmener sur les lieux même de la
mort du petit grégory de magistrats
voulaient tenter d'établir avec
certitude l'endroit où le corps d'un
enfant a été jeté dans la vologne il est
à trois ans pendant toute la matinée les
expériences ont été multipliés et l'
enquête a peut être avancé d'un pas
jusqu'ici il semble est vraisemblable
que le crime avait été commis à l'écart
du village de dos elle en contrebas de
cette voie ferrée sur place des
empreintes de pneus correspondant pas
celle de la voiture de christine
villemin et une trace de talents de
femmes avaient été relevés
deux éléments importants dans
l'hypothèse de la culpabilité de la
jeune femme
mais le juge simon semble maintenant
penser que jeter de cet endroit le corps
n'aurait pas pu dériver jusqu'à
l'emplacement où il a finalement été
retrouvé
grégory aurait en fait été assassiné ici
même en plein coeur du village
dans ce cas difficile de croire que le
meurtre était commis en plein jour sous
le regard d'éventuels témoins l'assassin
aurait plus vraisemblablement attendu la
tombée de la nuit une heure à laquelle
christine villemin était avec sa famille
à la recherche de son fils aujourd'hui
la défense a sans doute marqué un point
mais le juge simon attendra la fin de l'
enquête pour fonder son intime
conviction